[Musique]
salon de l'agriculture c'est avant tout
une vitrine du monde agricole
mais la vraie ambiance du monde agricole
sur leur insatisfaction leur souffrance
c'est sur le terrain dans les fermes
pour loi mais pas vraiment au salon de
l'agriculture
la méthode du gouvernement c'est d'être
très mobilisés dans les discours par
contre dans les actes et dans les faits
il n'y a aucune mobiliser si on a
l'impression qu'ils ne se rendent pas
tout à fait compte de la réalité des
difficultés du monde agricole
il s'auto persuadent que la loi ghanem
peut avoir une efficacité ont relié
jamais cru puisque ne traite que très
peu de sujets livrer le et dont dispose
le politique c'est pas le prix alors on
peut juste hicules et faire un certain
nombre de règles pour essayer que ça se
passe le moins mal possible mais dans le
revenu des agriculteurs ce qui a été
complètement oublié c'est que c'est la
différence entre les charges et les
produits et le politique ne peut agir
que sur la colonne charge que l'on
produit aussi oui les discussions
concernant la politique agricole commune
mais on n'a jamais touché à la colonne
charge jeudi on n'y a jamais touché la
loi et gagner me touche mais dans le
mauvais sens
c'est à dire en mettant des charges aux
agriculteurs pas comme ça qu'on va faire
du bien
[Musique]